[Music]
right this is the way it was unset a lot
of disagreements on who's doing press
and I guess I'll have one of you throw
each other under the bus who ruined the
most takes and why that was gonna be me
isn't it with me and Toby you can't
corpsing because he's dead the boob line
and then I said I I broke character and
we had to do like it's 15 tanks it was
like it was not good see you're
professional that would oh yeah no he
does it no I do I do I do I have got
reputation of a corpse er you know the
thing with this we're doing such long
takes as well it's quite hard especially
when it's very quiet that's when I find
it the hardest to same zone some of the
takes are like three minutes long yeah
blue age which is a long time to stay in
I saw the first five episodes and this
is a creepy at time show I'm just gonna
give you guys props I'm looking forward
to finishing the series um how much did
you guys know about the whole arc of the
season when you first signed on and how
much was it sort of like night or Toni
saying here's how it's gonna go just
trust us it's gonna be you know what I
mean I think it was yeah what we got we
got sent eight episodes to cut out a
mystery I did get a little bit heated
yeah but no I mean it would I would tell
you but nothing
when I first I really only read the
first three and actually originally was
just one saying there was these two guys
having this really intense conversation
about the dog and they instantly kind of
sparked my curiosity he stood you had no
idea kind of where this was going what
was happening and it was yeah I think
also because they're quite short scripts
as well they'll be just incredibly
addictive and you just wanted to know
more and more and yeah it's very very
clearly written yeah I burned through
the first eight so I got sent one once
episode when I did my audition and then
when we got I got the part they sent me
lay and I read them all in one sitting
and they kept it right to the end until
we got the last two so we were like
what's gonna happen we had no idea
that's me right now yeah whatever thing
is I think that's really cool about this
is that it's very realistic it's like
what would really happen if this
situation were to arise I'm can you sort
of talk about that aspect of the show
yes it's a very kind of realistic look
into this world but it also has this
kind of image it makes you an it's kind
of thing is there kind of some sort of
supernatural thing going on here and
you're constantly asking these questions
about the characters of thing are they
good or are they've had and you don't
really know it's very unsettling in that
in that respect yeah um I think that
like at the core of this story is about
people so I guess it was just trying to
translate how people will react in the
most natural way we could and yeah I
think there are lots of different
realities and it's sort of like pick
which reality I mean my characters are
different reality as to what's actually
going on Rupert's character does
everyone is seeing this story play out
differently so sort of pick your pick
your person who you think has got it
right I guess you you started with a
knight as the director I think he did
another episode but then you had a lot
of different directors what is it like
making a series like this when you have
different sort of Headmaster's if you
will coming into you know direct I think
the further along we got in the project
the more it sort of started to feel like
a group sort of dynamic I don't know it
was always always very collaborative
from the outset with night and when
everyone but I think when we got more
acquainted with the story and with
characters you know there are people
coming in coming in and out but we
and we stayed and we lived through the
whole thing so I think that that made us
slightly more well-versed on what we
wanted to achieve so we all just worked
together so it was it was interesting to
have people come in and out something
you're so close to you know mmm I think
so we never leave the house as well soon
it was got even the same kind of canvas
in each kind of episode it was
interesting having we were very lucky
about some great directors coming in and
I love Sierra as Nell says night was
always kind of behind the scenes kind of
a close eye on everything but it was
yeah it was interesting interesting I've
never really kind of filmed anything
like it because it was because being in
that house the geography of the house is
it kind of dictates how kind of how you
shoot things and a lot of things were
kind of like one set up scenes once the
whole scene would be it take so it was
quite an interesting like working i felt
quite almost like a play yeah at the
time when you think back on the making
of the show is there like a day or two
you're always gonna remember like
memorable moments were filming yeah I
literally have eel all day was a quite
quite a big officer they had these live
eels and and dead eels no heels were
harmed in the making of salad and I'm
vegetarian and I'm like incredibly
squeamish and it comes to stuff like
that and the eels are being like skinned
and doing stabbed and like dead dead
ones and everything like stabbed and
palm like this drill and I threw up in a
bucket on set now the world knows it was
it during a tea
it was not during the tape no they
probably would have used them that's
great no I ran off to the side and
chummed in a bucket okay yeah that was
probably my most memorable day I would
say what's your most memorable day I
don't know there was said there was a
lot that that does to count even though
I wasn't there I still have the memory
of the aftermath of that but yeah I mean
everything the thing with this the
script every kind of episode has this
you just kind of surreal kind of set
piece that plays out and there's a lot I
mean just anything with the doll was
kind of quite memorable not quite hasn't
left my mind yet oh sure I've been
asking this of everyone recently what TV
show besides your own would you like to
guest star on Glee there's nothing wrong
with that you're quite good singer oh
thanks did a bit karaoke we did we sung
a whole new world
yep which is which is that like a bar or
like a very public place
oh my god it's like a private room we
did have a probably you I am yeah holy
well we did do well but you forgot your
favorite thing my favorite way don't you
dare close your eyes it when he kind of
whispers don't you dare close your eyes
I miss that
and kind of threw me off for the rest of
the song and that note I gotta go
congratulations on this I hope all the
interviews go well